esta es una imagen de pantalla de la
sección de ejercicios de demostraciones
de líneas y ángulos en khan academy y
pienso que podemos usarlo para practicar
las demostraciones de líneas y ángulos y
lo genial de esto es que aquí podemos
usar transformaciones traslaciones y
rotaciones como forma de hacer estas
demostraciones nos dicen l es el punto
sobre el segmento m n que eki vista de
las líneas
jm y mk jn y emeka son líneas paralelas
vamos a verlo este es el diagrama nos
están diciendo que el segmento nos está
diciendo que él es el punto sobre el
segmento m n que equidista tiene la
misma distancia de las líneas jn y emeka
entonces tenemos aquí nuestro punto l
en el segmento m n que x vista de los
segmentos jm ib
meca que más nos dicen jm y emeka son
líneas paralelas efectivamente
jn y emeka son paralelas muy bien que
más realiza una rotación que demuestre
que los ángulos alternos internos
siempre son iguales y elige la opción
que mejor explica la demostración veamos
cuáles son estos ángulos alternos
internos
si tenemos estas paralelas y está
transversal estos ángulos internos y
alternos internos porque van hacia
adentro de lo que se forma con la línea
paralela y la transversal y son alternos
porque bueno están como que viendo hacia
el lados diferentes oa lados contrarios
entonces tenemos que hacer una rotación
para demostrar que este ángulo
es igual que este ángulo b como lo voy a
hacer
bueno aquí tengo esta herramienta que
dice rotas
y aquí me ponen este puntito y estas
flechas lo que tengo que hacer es
encontrar cuál de los puntos que tengo
aquí me sirve para rotar de manera que
se vea que este ángulo a es igual al
ángulo b entonces vamos a ver qué pasa
si lo roto aquí sobre él vamos a hacer
clic aquí encima vemos que rota
y
curiosamente si me está sirviendo así es
como me parece esto tengo mi ángulo ha
marcado aquí tengo mi ángulo b pero lo
que se va a mover es lo que está en azul
que es esta línea y esta línea que
forman mi ángulo a entonces vamos a
moverlo lo estoy rotando lo estoy
rotando hasta que hago coincidir de
nuevo esta línea con este segmento está
línea coincide con la paralela
recordamos que es esta de aquí es la
rotación de esta de aquí y tengo que
efectivamente el ángulo de aquí el b es
igual al ángulo que rote del a muy bien
esto es lo que hice si yo muevo esto a
ver voy a regresarlo como estaba
si yo tomar este punto y a lo mejor
quisiera rotarlo no sé de aquí en el
punto m si lo nuevo pues va a rotar pero
pues no me va a señalar nada en
particular del ángulo b que me interesa
nada más estoy poniéndolo pues de nuevo
coincidente con esta línea transversal
si éste lo muevo algún otro ángulo
y nada más puedo hacer que quede como
que medio paralelo aquí un paralelogramo
más o menos pero pues no me sirve para
lo que me están pidiendo entonces lo que
hice voy a hacer deshacer
es rotar entonces
sobre él
lo giro y ccoo pero que coinciden
exactamente estas líneas formando el
mismo ángulo que acá veamos cuáles son
las opciones que me dan la rotación de
180 grados alrededor de l l es el punto
que elegimos que se esté aquí está
ap al punto j en el punto k y el punto m
este punto j lo mueve hasta aquí acá
y el punto en el mapa nm
qué más nos dice esto es lo que hemos
estado haciendo las rotaciones preservan
las distancias así que el ángulo k ml
debe ser igual al ángulo jn l el ángulo
k ml es el ángulo b y el ángulo
jn l es el a jm l es este ángulo y en
efecto todo esto es lo que hicimos y
comprobamos que se preservan estos
ángulos así que es mi opción correcta de
todas maneras leemos las siguientes
opciones la rotación de 180 grados
alrededor de m mp al segmento m k en sí
mismo y mn en sí mismo entonces lo que
hicimos pues bueno no fue esto se supone
que las rotaciones en m y tengo que
moverlo y en los segmentos de hecho no
puedo hacer que sea línea
esto no me sirve esta segunda opción no
es la correcta la rotación es 180 grados
alrededor de ce mapea el segmento jn en
mk vemos el punto ce bueno de entrada no
tengo ningún punto ce así que esta pues
no aplica porque no tengo un c para
hacer una rotación
entonces queremos que la opción buena es
la primera opción comprobamos respuestas
y es correcta vamos a hacer otro
ejercicio nos dicen que la línea v y el
segmento c o d son líneas rectas cuál de
estas proposiciones demuestra que los
ángulos opuestos por el vértice siempre
son iguales los ángulos verticales son
los ángulos que se encuentran en lados
opuestos de una intersección así que por
ejemplo el ángulo 12 y el ángulo de v
son ángulos verticales y si queremos
demostrar que son iguales pues sus
medidas tienen que ser iguales así que
teta debe ser igual a fin veamos cuáles
de estos enunciados resuelven esto nos
dicen las rotaciones preservan las
longitudes y los ángulos el segmento ave
es congruente con el segmento cde
entonces sabemos que fi es igual a teta
de hecho no sabemos si el segmento ave
es congruente con el segmento cde así
que esto podemos descartarlo de a más la
segunda opción si tanto el radio
como el radio o se se rotan por 180
grados a alrededor del punto o ambos
deben apearse en el radio o b y d
respectivamente si se rotan los radios
por la misma cantidad el ángulo entre
estos no cambiará así que si debe ser
igual a teta vamos a ver esto esto suena
interesante vamos a analizar lo que nos
dicen así que si tomamos el rayo oa que
es este y lo rotamos 180 grados va a
moverse todo esto de aquí y apuntar en
esta otra dirección y se va a mapear al
rayo v así que esto sí me suena que está
bien el rayo
se va a mapear con el rayo v si el rayo
se gira 180 grados y el rayo o sé si lo
notamos 180 grados va a mapear al rayo o
d así que este primer enunciado es
cierto
si tanto el rayo como el rayo se rotan
por 180 grados alrededor del punto o
ambos deben apearse en el rayo v y el
rayo o d respectivamente y cuando
decimos respectivamente estamos
refiriéndonos a que van a estar en el
mismo orden el rayo o a mapear a al rayo
v y el rayo o se va a mapear al rayo o d
y esto lo vimos el rayo
se llama pea al rayo v si lo rotamos 180
grados y si tomamos el rayo 11 y lo
notamos 180 grados vamos a mapear al
rayo o d así que esto me suena bastante
lógico y realmente estoy de acuerdo con
esto si se rotan dos rayos por la misma
cantidad el ángulo entre estos no
cambiará así que fin debe ser igual a
teta y esto es cierto si hacemos esto
que nos dice es el segundo enunciado va
a ser verdadero si rotamos dos rayos por
la misma cantidad el ángulo que se forma
entre estos dos
no va a cambiar y con lo que hicimos
aquí derrotar el rayo y el rayo hace 180
grados quedamos que coinciden con el
rayo v y el rayo o the end
respectivamente así que el ángulo fin es
igual al ángulo theta esta segunda
opción es correcta vamos a ver qué nos
dice la tercera opción tenemos el
segmento am es congruente con el
segmento de y el segmento o b es
congruente con el segmento o c de hecho
no tengo que seguir leyendo lo que falta
del enunciado para concluir que esta
opción es falsa ya que lo que nos están
diciendo aquí pues no tenemos forma de
saber si es cierto al menos no con la
información que nos están dando yo no sé
si el segmento oa es congruente con el
segmento ode no tenga información para
encontrar esto así que ni le sigo
buscando esta opción no es verdadera
sino la segunda opción esa es la buena y
lo único que necesitamos aquí fue
visualizar esto con más detalle que si
tomamos el ángulo
y lo rotamos 180 grados significa que
vamos a tomar los rayos correspondientes
y los rotamos 180 grados vamos a llegar
al ángulo veo de y el ángulo entre ambos
rayos o la medida del ángulo entre estos
rayos de los que estamos hablando no van
a cambiar así que definitivamente es
esta segunda opción comprobamos
respuesta es correcta